Gal and I are about to face off
in a game of Box of Lies.
Here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects neither of us
have seen before.
Taking turns,
we're going to select a box,
open it on our side
of the table,
out of view of the other person.
You remove the object
from the box,
show it to our
great audience here,
and then look at your opponent
and tell them
what's in your box.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Gal, why don't you pick
the first box?
-Oh, thank you.
How gentleman of you.
-Yes.
-Any idea?
[ Audience shouting ]
5.
-I will get it for you.
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-It feels very light.
-Hmm.
-So that's a hint.
-Oh, my God.
This is awesome.
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Hmm. Yes?
-You know --
-What is in your box?
What was in your box?
-What I'm hiding...
-Yes.
-...in my box...
[ Laughter ]
It moves. You can hear
the sound of the movement.
Can you hear it?
-No.
-The squeak.
-Squeak?
-Like, it sounds like a squeak.
I don't know if it's a squeak.
Like, it's an "eeeh!"
Never mind.
It's --
-What? What?
-It --
-It sounds like a squeak?
-You're lying.
-It moves. It moves.
-It moves. Yeah, yeah. Okay,
that one -- That's the truth.
It's from -- made out of
plastic. It's an animal.
It's an elephant
made out of plastic.
And it's thing -- trunk.
Trunk? Moves.
-Yes, trunk.
-Yeah.
-All right, so it's a plastic
elephant with a moving trunk.
-Uh-huh.
I don't see why you
would be lying about that.
I think you're telling
the truth!
-You're so wrong! Ha ha!
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are the -- Oh, my gosh!
-I told you I would do better...
-Gosh! Dumb.
"Cats rule"?
Get this thing out of here.
All right. Which number?
[ Audience shouting ]
Here we go. 2. I can't believe
you got me with that.
[ Grunting ]
-Acting as if it's very heavy.
-Oh, I don't know. Is it?
-But it seems to be
really light.
Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
You don't know
if you should lie about it
since it's such a good thing...
-Yeah.
-...or you should just
go for it, right?
Okay.
-It's a Cabbage Patch doll head.
-What is that?
-You don't have that in Israel?
-A Cabbage what?
-Cabbage Patch dolls.
Cabbage Patch doll.
-What is that?
-Cabbage Patch kids?
It's, like, a famous doll.
Do you have dolls?
Did you have dolls growing up?
-Yeah, we have dolls in Israel.
Just not...
-All right.
Well, this is a doll head of a
very famous toy here in America.
-Oh, the sweet, cute, little...
-Yes.
...girly, yeah.
But this has Cheerios
glued to its head
made to look like an afro.
[ Laughter ]
-You're lying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I've never lost.
This is embarrassing.
All right.
Well, what number for you?
[ Audience shouting ]
-7.
I'm being very nice
and gentlemanly.
[ Grunts ]
-It's not heavy at all.
You're playing an act --
-No, I'm very --
I know, but I'm just --
I'm just --
I don't like losing.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even know
how to describe this.
-Hmm. Right now -- Right now
what's going through your head?
You're thinking of lying,
you're thinking of
telling the truth.
It's a very mixed bag right now.
You're going through a lot
of emotions, and I feel that.
It's a foot.
-Food?
[ Laughter ]
Like foot? Or food?
Foot? You said "foot."
So that means it's --
Is it a food --
you eat food?
Or foot with toes?
-It's a foot.
-Oh, foot. It's a foot.
Yeah. It's a foot.
I mean, but this is --
You're charming me now.
So this is --
This is all part of the thing.
Oh, this is a good lie.
You just totally gave it up.
'Cause now you're being
really charming.
-With, um...
-It is a foot.
-With, like...
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
What is it, now?
-With, like, small, little
people skiing off the foot.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. This is a foot --
It's a foot with small, little
people skiing off the foot.
[ Laughter ]
-You are really good.
You're a really good actor.
All right. Gosh.
I don't know if you're lying
or telling the truth.
It's a foot with people
skiing off the foot.
I think you lie!
-I tell the truth!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I lost!
[ Bell dinging ]
You are good.
Congratulations.
You are the winner.
Now, as the winner...
♪♪
-Gal, as the winner of this...
-Yes.
-...we have
a special prize for you.
-Yay!
-Our writer Seth Herzog
is going to come out
and do a tribute to you
by doing an interpretive dance
of the original
"Wonder Woman" theme song.
-That would be amazing!
-So here he is.
-Where is he?
-Give it up for Seth Herzog.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Wonder Woman" theme plays ]
-♪ Wonder Woman, Wonder Woman ♪
-♪ All our hopes
are pinned upon you ♪
-♪ And the magic that you do ♪
♪ Stop a bullet cold
and make the axis fold ♪
♪ Change their minds ♪
♪ And change the world ♪
♪ Wonder Woman ♪
♪ You're a wonder,
Wonder Woman ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up for
Seth Herzog, everybody!
Let's hear it for Gal Gadot!
Once again "Wonder Woman"
and "Wonder Woman" meet.
We'll be right back
with Barry Manilow.
You cannot unsee that.
♪♪